this is definitely the sort of seat of
thanks and so I want to echo some of the
thank-yous that were made earlier to the
to the Lewis Walpole library for being
utterly formative in my second book and
it's a kind of ongoing relationship for
which I'm very grateful I especially
want to thank Cindy for asking me to
direct the mysterious mother well I have
a few eighteenth-century restoration
comedies under my belt I had never tried
my hand at tragedy and she she both
trusted me with it and kind of talked me
into it and I'm so so glad you did
I also want to do one other thank you
for someone who has been for me in this
project behind the scenes and a huge
help and that's Joe Roche Joe challenged
me about seven years ago to do the
scholarship of performance and it was
one of those suggestions that was
utterly transformative for my
professional life and my intellectual
life and my students lives so I just
want to thank you for that Joe it's it's
definitely enhanced my ongoing love
affair with the 18th century all right
well when we started rehearsals for the
mysterious mother lo these many three
days ago the first thing I said to the
cast is the only way out of this play is
over the top
we were we were faced with a less than
48 hour start to finish process and a
play that is genuinely interesting and
so that over-the-topness played itself
out in a few different ways for those of
you who weren't in on the secret the two
evil priests were played by an actual
priest and a Catholic theologian we also
went to some pains mostly Cindy's pains
to try to reproduce the beauclerk
illustrations in our lavish costuming
which included a little gift from the
universe when we got Florian's costume
back that beautiful purple costume we
were told it was insured for extra and
it's it's a very beautiful costume
because it was worn by a famous person
when he took it off the rack and looked
in the tag it said mr. Lane
it was worn by Nathan
sometime in the 70s so everything here
is over-the-top even the Nathan Lane
connection and finally it felt over the
top or puckish or downright heretical to
be projecting images of this Gothic
castle on Louie Kahn's clean modernist
wall and see it works so well so the
cast has already been working on the
musical we rehearse mama mia last night
after after the show and we have a
social media campaign it's hashtag who's
your daddy so this panel is about
staging the mysterious mother and in our
in the process that we just went through
I think we experienced some of the
negotiations that earlier panelists have
already talked about our first
negotiation was sort of with the seen
and the unseen in this play ah and
that's reflected in the way we were
negotiating David's brilliant cut back
with the original text and the things
that we could not play but tried to show
you or let you hear we also were I think
always negotiating that line between
camp and tragedy which turns out to be a
really productive space and we found
things that we didn't expect to find so
we hope that that inquiry will continue
with these papers so first we will hear
from Marci Frank Marci is a professor of
English at Concordia in Montreal and she
teaches mainly 18th century literature
she's finishing a book the novel's stage
from comedy of manners to melodrama
which is about the ways that theatrical
conventions shaped the novel between the
restoration and Jane Austen
her most recent essay on contemporary
American queer writer Dennis Cooper
Cooper's queer objects and I have to go
read this now um can be read in the
current issue of angelic a oh my all
right that's my that's my bid and the
title of her talk today is willful
Walpole performing publication in the
mysterious mother
hi and thanks for coming and thanks for
having me - Jonathan Kramnik and Jill
Campbell and it's I'm delighted to be
here to share my work with you and I
really enjoyed the staging and we'll see
what you think about this the mystery of
the Countess of Narbonne the mysterious
mother for whom Horace Walpole's Gothic
tragedy is named is established at the
outset of the play by elaborate varied
and even contradictory discussion of her
motivations before she appears the
porter describes her virtuous piety and
the priests Martin and Benedict discuss
her proud secrecy if her self-reliant
despair gives her some dignity when she
first comes on stage at the end of Act
one
Florian's reflections on her treatment
of her son Edmund at the beginning of
act to complicate without rendering
comprehensible her character he even
depicts her mourning the death of her
husband as hypocritical sable chambers
the winking lamp the pomp of midnight
whoa are but a specious theater on which
the inconstant mind with decency forgets
its inward tribute language that
resonates with the Castle of Otranto
introduces his ironic question who can
doubt the love which to a father's shade
devotes the Sun the answer
the mysterious mother who has banished
that son and determined that he can only
enjoy his inheritance from afar holy
shades of Hamlet Batman for Florian
Edmonds Robin the male line has been
interrupted by the excessive performance
a female grief set in a specious theatre
the mystery of the mysterious mother is
sustained until the plays end when the
countess reveals to Edmund that his
marriage to ad Eliza is incestuous not
only because she is his sister but also
because she is his daughter the
offspring of a sexual encounter he
unbeknownst to himself had enjoyed with
his own mother who disguised herself as
his beloved Beatrice on the very night
of her
Ben's death the countess then kills
herself though she initially inspires
pity and Martin and Benedict who schemed
to acquire her property for the church
invite skeptical distrust when her crime
is revealed in quote a moment as Walpole
himself described it in the PostScript
quote a most odious moment of depraved
imagination and quote the play is
evacuated of any internal ground of
moral judgment for the dark reversal
does not restore the respectability of
the church Walpole knew that the double
incest would render the play unperformed
well yet he nevertheless adapted it to
the scene he exhibited a similar
ambivalence about its publication today
I want to suggest that the specious
theatre of the mysterious mother with
its ambiguous relation to performance
and it's strange publication history
provides us with the template for
Walpole's other endeavors Walt will
recognized that the suppression of the
countess's secret was essential to the
whole design of the play as he observed
in the in the PostScript for the
addition of fifty he initially printed
at Strawberry Hill in 1768 in order
quote to palliate the crime and raise
the character of the criminal the
audience must be prejudiced in her favor
for this reason he further explained I
suppressed the story till the last scene
and bestowed every ornament of sense on
Baqi did pity piety an interesting
contrition on the character that was at
last to raise Universal indignation
singling out some features of the play
for critical appreciation quote terror
and pity naturally arise from the
subject the moral is just and it
conforms to the three neoclassical
unities he nevertheless distinguished
his desire of striking a little out of
the common road to introduce some
novelty onto our stage he risked the
disgust he knew the play would provoke
and though he apologized for it he also
implied it was justified for the
introduction of the new character of the
mysterious mother he echoed these
thoughts in thoughts on tragedy composed
in 1775 but only published in the
posthumous complete works of 1798 the
thoughts take the form of three letters
to Robert
sinn who's play the count of noir bond
was a successful adaptation of the
Castle of Otranto that as its title
suggests amalgamated elements of the
mysterious mother it premiered in 1781
and was performed 37 times up to 1798
quote if there is any merit in my play I
think it is in interrupting the
spectators fathoming the whole story
till the last and in making every scene
tend to advance the catastrophe
exhibiting a self-consciousness about
his strengths and weaknesses as a
playwright Walpole remarked on his
attraction to the topic of incest and
passed on a story idea for one of his
favorite subjects Don Carlos as Walpole
explained to Jefferson quote why I gave
up this fruitful canvas was merely
because the passion is incestuous as is
most unfortunately that of my mysterious
mother though at different points in
time and that of Carlos a pardonable and
not disgusting one I shall rejoice at
having left it if you will adapt it
adopt it sorry suggesting that Jefferson
adopt a story less controversial than
his own Walpole here encouraged his
protege by his own example evidently
Walpole relished his provocative effects
on others and here I'm going to
recapitulate some of the publication
history that we heard about from Dale
this morning in the short preface he
wrote for the edition of the play he let
Dodds leap print in London in 1781 which
he claimed to be preventing to which he
claimed to be publishing only to prevent
piracy waffle again warded off blame
with apology quote he cannot be more
blamed than he blames himself for having
undertaken so disagreeable a story and
for hazarding the publicity by letting
it go out of his hands in quote
Peter Sabre has observed that Walpole's
vexed attitude for publication is taken
to a compulsive level with the
mysterious mother he desired to
circulate in print and to withhold
himself from such circulation by means
of which he could control critical
response the preface to Dolly's edition
is dated April 29 1781 two letters of
later that year one to Conway dated May
20
and the other two mason dated July 3rd
indicate that though notice of
publication prevented the spurious
edition it went ahead anyways Walpole
however retained the Edition and
circulated copies to friends as he had
also done with the 1768 edition printed
at Strawberry Hill Jeff since the count
of Nirvana was printed by Thomas Cadell
right after its premiere with the
dedication from Justin to Walt to
Walpole dated November 17th 1781 I'm
here floating a speculation that even
though Walpole didn't say so himself
perhaps he sought to coordinate the
printing of his own tragedy with the
performance of Jefferson's play he was
involved with Jefferson's production in
other ways including having loaned
Alfonso's armor even though he didn't
circulate the publication of the play he
may have wanted to have some printed
copies available to restate interest in
coordination with with the production of
Jefferson's plain wall who was right to
be concerned about the reactions his
play would produce Francis Burnie
recorded her disgust upon the discovery
of the countess's secret when she
participated in a closeted reading of
the play she felt quote a sort of
intimate indignant aversion rise fast
and warm in my mind against the willful
author of a story so horrible all the
entertainment and pleasure I received
from mr. Walpole seemed extinguished by
his lecture Burnie strong response as
her narrative of her reading experience
shows derives from our initial enjoyment
of the play and the interest it elicited
in the character of the countess her
indignant aversion be speaks a betrayal
of expectations which he directs against
the quote willful author of a story so
horrible both wobbles consistent
reflections on the disgust the play must
induce and Bernie's response indicate
that the play is that the plays
streamline structure was integral to its
design it's smooth acceleration made its
ultimate revelation all the more
offensive though many critics understand
Walpole's native English gothic to be
opposed to a neoclassicism associated
with the French
walpole who's frank Ophelia is complex
but there demonstrates a strategic
neoclassicism that serves to manage
innovation while maintaining audience
appeal in the PostScript he minimized
his investment in critical approbation
of the plate for abiding by the rules
even though he himself introduced those
features for a praised quote if the
critics be pleased that this conformity
to their laws with this conformity to
their laws I shall be glad to have their
satisfaction though for my own part I
set little value on such merit which was
accidental and at best mechanic and have
a subordinate client and were apt
bruised to produce improbable situations
that remove them so this sort of typical
double gesture that lets him praise
himself and then not take it away an
ideal venue for self-expression and the
manipulation of response in many
respects the mysterious mother occasions
and emblematic performance of locals
authorship that theater pervaded
Walpole's authorship can be seen across
his writings the Castle of Otranto
entered the world as Walpole's
production under Shakespeare's mantle
and Marshall Brown has described it as
formal transmutation of restoration
tragedy Walpole's treatment of his 1773
comedy nature will prevail mirrors that
of his tragedy he sent it to George
Coleman at Covent Garden who quote press
to have it enlarged but then as the
short notes on the life of Horatio
Walpole record he quote would not take
the trouble to do so for so slayed an
extemporary a performance earlier in his
career and Dale also talked about these
forays into a theatrical composition he
had written the dear witches a political
pamphlet in dramatic form that parodies
the which is seen in Macbeth it was laid
out with a list of dramatis personae 5
scene divisions and scene and stage
directions when it was published in the
Whig Journal Old England he also enjoyed
his own capacity produced to produce
discussed in tale four of the
hieroglyphic tales for example in which
the Archbishop of two um drinks an
aborted fetus he had missed
bacon for a peach in brandy critics have
long agreed that waffles over exhibits a
remarkable consistency across genres and
media including architecture gardening
and collecting which has led to psycho
biographical reflections and
disquisitions on taste
recently Shaun silver has proposed that
the design of and writing about the
villa at Strawberry Hill are emblematic
of Walpole's understanding of history
proposing that the villa served as a
sort of enlarged wunderkammer
silverton's into the experiences Walpole
sought to supply his visitors though he
doesn't bring out the connections
between historiography as grand house
tour and the theater building on
Silver's account
James Lillie brilliantly grasps the
effective intensities and strenuous
demands of Walpole's double conception
of uniqua t as collectible the
singularity with no intrinsic value that
is common and may even have been
produced more than once as in an old
Roman shoe whose worth is independent of
its former wearer and the rare curiosity
of a monstrous birth both operate on the
margins of the market remaining
collectible only to the discerning eye
the specious theatre of the mysterious
mother conforms to both aspects of
iniquity depicting the suspension of the
patrilineal lines so that the disgusting
generativity of the maternal can be
revealed and then expunged the place
subject matter is monstrous birth
unperformed ball and yet intermittent in
intermittent circulation the plays
singularity is redoubled guaranteed by
its appearances in print as the
mysterious mother brings out more
clearly than any other example willful
Walpole enjoyed provoking and amusing
his coterie and then sought to extend
the circle to strangers provided that
they proved their eligibility for
mentorship by withstanding his tests
tests that included their capacity to
enjoy disgust and to admire triviality
thank you so much for that paper Marcin
our second speaker will be Jean Marcin
here's a professor of English at the
University of Connecticut she's the
author of several books including the
reimagined text Shakespeare adaptation
an 18th century literary theory fatal
desire women's sexuality in the English
stage and theaters of feeling effect and
performance on the 18th century stage
this last one forthcoming here be
notified she is also the associate
editor of the works of Anne Finch as
well as numerous articles on restoration
in eighteenth-century theatre her title
today is family dramas the mysterious
mother and the eighteenth-century incest
play so thank you and thank you for
letting me be a part of this even though
I'm not really a Walpole Ian so
guilt-ridden ravaged woman agonizes
about a crime she committed sixteen
years ago when she took the place of a
maid who had arranged a tryst with her
son as the result of this liaison she
becomes pregnant and gives birth to a
daughter claiming that the girl is an
orphan she raises her until she at the
age of 16 when her banished son returns
home sees the beautiful girl and marries
her consternation occurs and the woman
stabs herself in a fit of fear of frenzy
sound familiar what I've just described
as the plot of the fatal discovery or
love and ruins an anonymous late 17th
century tragedy despite these
similarities I do not mean to claim that
the fatal discoveries the source for
Walpole's play he claims that he got the
idea from a real-life event although the
advertisement for the 19th set in 97
1791 Dublin Edition does refer to this
contemptible performance
as a means of praising Walpole's greater
delicacy in keeping his play off the
public stage rather my interest today
lies and considering the mysterious
mother in the context of three other
plays that like the fatal discovery deal
with intro with incest as the crisis
point for the tragedy unlike the fatal
discovery all three plays were
successful in their own time and were
staged well into the 18th century the
first two plays I want to consider focus
on brothers sister incest and represent
the horror it visits on the unwilling
participants the first is the most
popular of all eighteen restoration in
eighteenth-century incest plays Thomas
Otways the orphan in which Polydor takes
his brother's place in bed with Mona Mia
the titular orphan and here we get
echoes of orphanage from paper this
morning
what Polydor thought was simply an
illicit assignation was actually cast a
Leos and manila's wedding night making
this bed trick and act however unwitting
of incest brother with sister-in-law
once discovered both participants
recognized the act as a pollution that
can never be removed it is a horrid deed
that results in the suicide of both
participants as well as the sinned
against kills cast a Leo a more involved
but less catastrophic example occurs in
den Dryden's Don Sebastian in which the
hero weds his half-sister a relationship
the two discover after the fact in doing
so they ignore repeated wet warnings and
admonitions from other characters as
well as prophecies from the past and in
this it's reminiscent of the greatest of
all incest plays Sophocles Oedipus a
play that was adapted by Dryden in LA
and Lee more than a decade earlier
Sebastian and his bride Amelia
consummate their marriage before the
relationship is known but unlike the
orphans bloody conclusion they separate
- two distant convent and
Bastien to a desert hermitage a fate
similar to Walpole's edward and add
eliza Atalissa sorry Walpole's
two innocent sinners these plays detai
deal with brothers sister incest and
while they are reminiscent of the edward
analyzed a storyline and the mysterious
mother
they have little in common with the
central focus of will of Walpole's play
the countess and the act that torments
her a greatest greater interest here is
edmund Smith's
Phaedra and Hippolytus a play originally
staged in 1707 with an all-star cast
including Thomas Betterton Elizabeth
Barry and an old field Smith's play went
through multiple editions and remained
in the repertoire through the end of the
18th century Smith was a Greek scholar
and David Erskine Baker describes
Phaedra and Hippolytus as a scholars
play play has several interesting
parallels to the mysterious mother the
most obvious of these is the nature of
the incestuous desire mother for son in
this case a stepson although Phaedra's
incestuous desires have never acted upon
the fact that she did that she desires
Hippolytus while considering him her son
has made clear she describes her
feelings as a beastial passion while
stressing the exact nature of her sinful
desire and exclaiming near the beginning
of the play Oh can you keep it from
yourselves unknowing or do you think I'm
so gone in guilt that I can see bear the
looks the eyes of one who knows my black
detested crimes who knows that Phaedra
loves her son there is no secondary
incest in Phaedra and Hippolytus and we
discover early in the first act the
nature of Phaedra's sin
Vedran Hippolytus opens with lichen a
scheming Minister of State who much like
Walpole's Benedict plots throughout to
destroy the plays heroine Smith's
character however is more successful
than Benedict
prompting his victim to curtain to
confess her sin and under the guise of
white count wise counsel he uses it to
torment her further urging her at one
point to yield to her husband thesis
theseus's desires advice that she
regards with [ __ ] exclaiming in the
father's arms Oh horrid thought Oh
excellence essed
even in the father's arms embrace the
Sun and this rather lurid passage was
omitted from the bells edition in 1777
in the end she liked the countess stabs
herself in a fit of guilt when ridden
frenzy while Smith's play was generally
plays by praised by critics some took
offense with Phaedra's willingness to
confess her crime in front of an
audience
seeing the event of her speech as an act
almost as grotesque as the incestuous
desire itself even Dryden's Norma Hall
in Oran zeebee as Charles Gildan notes
kept quote her brutal passion to herself
not like the bolder Phaedra making
confidants and breathing her incestuous
desires in the face of a whole court
having incestuous desires is bad enough
articulating these desires to others
constitutes an even greater sin Walpole
himself stressed theologic if not the
sinfulness of having a character discuss
her sin in front of an audience
digressing from a discussion of full
Greville two-state quote with all the
difference of Grecian French and English
English manners it is impossible to
conceive that Phaedra trusted her
incestuous passions or Mead or Medea her
murderous revenge to a whole troupe of
attendants
well Walpole does not comment directly
on the criminality of Phaedra herself
his linking of her with the notorious
villainous Medea is suggested as of now
I have found no definitive proof that
Walpole knew
Smith's play but I feel certain that he
was familiar with it now I do not mean
by drawing these connections to suggest
that the mysterious mother is mainly is
just really a pastiche of tropes
commonly found in earlier plays rather
examining the places where it diverges
from the norms seen in other publicly
staged plays illuminates the uniqueness
of Walpole's tragedy uniqueness that I
would argue would have prevented it from
being staged able drama at least in the
18th century since we know from last
night's performance that we were able to
stage it in the 21st to do so I would
like to turn back to the fatal discovery
that contemptible performance with the
plot that so carefully parallels so
closely parallels that of the mysterious
mother bad though this play may be it
nevertheless possessed qualities that
allowed it to appear on the stage
something that would have been
impossible for Walpole's play no matter
how carefully he worked to engage
sympathy for his heroine
the most notable differences occur early
on in the play in the fatal discovery
ruin Daria the countess the countess
figure does not knowingly sleep with her
son rather she thought she was arranging
to sleep with her husband who had
abandoned her bed as her confidant ara
paisa later explains the convoluted
chain of events to Bart Baron Gauri as
son the night before you were sent to
travel you passed an engagement with a
young and foolish maid of the house to
meet that night your father had made
another such appointment which was by
one discovered - your mother and my
unhappy lady in her stead resolved to
meet her husband but by accident she did
mistake the room and came to you but in
the morning slipping from her husband as
she believed for fear of discovery she
met my lord just come from his intrigue
and then she found too late her fatal
error
like Phaedra Baron Darya has confessed
her guilt to a trusted confidant but in
her case the confidant taking on the
role of the playwright can remind burn
Daria and the audience that it was no
more her act was no more than a fatal
accident possibly even condoned by
heaven Berengaria concert' considers the
real source of her guilt to be her own
wanton love for her husband she should
have considered his desires not her own
and allowed him to continue with his
adulterous behavior her act while not
appropriately wifely and submissive was
nothing more than an accident
destructive yes but unintentional
by contrast Walpole's heroine is not the
victim of a fatal error in household
geography something that distinguishes
her from her predecessor because of this
woful explains he felt he need he felt
the need to palliate the crime first by
creating the figure of the evil monk
benedict and then by creating a
situation in which the countess was to
be imagined as thrown off her guard by a
combination of grief and disappointment
her fondness and her Hut for her husband
was thus in some measure the cause of
her guilt
if the countess's act was deliberate
even if it was not premeditated she
explains that in the moment when she
waited long lee for her husband's return
i mean some of these lines should be
familiar from last night's performance
she saw him presented a bloody course
before me I raved this storm of
disappointed passions assailed my reason
fevered all my blood and at that moment
she learns of Edmonds proposition to the
maid
thou canst not Harbor a foreboding
thought more dire than I conceived I
executed guilt rushed into my soul my
fancy saw thee thy father's image
grief disappointment opportunity raise
such a tumult in my madding blood I took
the damsels place this was no accident
no case of mistaken identity while the
countess's raw grief worn out of her
love for her husband may be a mitigating
factor there is no doubt she knew what
she was doing even if she could not
foresee the constants the consequences
of her crime this deliberate behavior
this articulated fact of incestuous
desire is what I suggest would have made
the mysterious mother unstageable a fact
that Walpole's friend William Mason as
we were just discussing implies when he
suggested a very few alterations that he
thought would make the play more stable
after praising the play he comments that
there is a capital defect in the demon
maintained umma and quote provoked it
proved the thing feasible there is a
sketchy sense of such alterations as I
think necessary his advice was to render
the incestuous act an accident the
result of the countess's supposed
jealousy over her husband in other words
to replicate the plot of the fatal
discovery that contrived but stage with
the drama
[Applause]
thank you very much team we're gonna
have lots to talk about the stage
ability verses on the stage ability I
can see in the talkback next it's my
pleasure to introduce al Coppola who is
an associate professor of English at
John Jay College in the CUNY system and
he's also the Past Chair of the Columbia
University seminar in 18th century
European culture his first book the
theatre of experiment staging natural
philosophy in eighteenth-century Britain
is a critical study of science in and as
performance his current book project
enlightenment visibility's studies the
18th century innovations that structure
21st century modernity by bringing
previously unimaginable or imperceptible
phenomena into the domain of perception
and knowledge now I would like to say
that I added in the lightning in last
night's show just for Al because he's
going to be talking to us about
lightning let's just call it serendipity
right so his title for us today is
spectacles of science and superstition
thank you so very much to Cindy and to
misty and to everyone that put this
together and for welcoming in someone
who I guess I can't really call myself a
Walpole Ian I'm actually not even gonna
be talking so much about literature
either today um because what I want to
think about is sort of the scientific
context that are circulating that I
think we want to put on the table so if
and I also you know I want us to think
about sort of the mysterious mother for
a range of reasons and certainly one of
the most important ones surely must be
how this notorious drama helped shape
that emergent form of the Gothic mode
what do we get when we situate this play
alongside Walpole's
endlessly Red Castle of Otranto as the
twin headwaters of the gothics murky
flow what was the context in the
catalyst for this plays mysterious
monstrous birth in 1617 6080 and what
can it teaches about the sources and
textures and meanings of
form so I'd like us to think about what
happens to the supernatural in Walpole's
gothic vision when we move from Otranto
to the mysterious mother certainly we've
got the gloomy moldering castle a motif
and there's certainly a has an abiding
sense that the places and spaces of this
story are accursed but in the mysterious
mother we find though examples of the
hallucinatory literalism we had in a
Toronto I'm thinking that preposterous
giant helmet so mad fastly and
insistently real that it kills a young
heir dead and even serves as a temporary
holding cell for a suspected mal factor
that helmet is a deliberate and weirdly
material signal that a Toronto is truly
haunted the gothic tale is straight-up
supernatural past crimes of usurpation
and cruelty do not merely persist in
guilty memory those wrongs are real and
the very palace is haunted by
supernatural agents that avenge them in
fulfillment of what had seemed like a
cryptically figurative prophecy turns
out the warning the castle and lordship
of a Toronto shall pass from the present
family whenever the real owner should be
grown too large to inhabit it
that was absurdly literal cue the
supernatural exit manfred running from a
giant but the mysterious mother is quite
different in fact it posits a
deliberately anti supernatural version
of the Gothic no Giants stalk these
ancient halls no skeletons rattle their
bones
Thaksin portraits are right out the
castle and heirs of Nar bone are
accursed for sure but there's no
evidence that supernatural agents are to
blame in fact the thunderstorm that we
did have to cut to make it stable but
that plays such an important role in act
2 scene 2 that so terrifies the denizens
of the place it triggers a pitched
battle about the very possibility of
supernatural agency and it becomes an
opportunity for Walpole to explicitly
disavow it so we begin with Florian and
had been meeting the procession of
orphaned children making a pilgrimage to
the counts grave on the anniversary of
his sudden death when Florian overhears
the scheming priest Martin encouraged
the children's superstitious belief that
the count is haunting
the the shrine the blunt-talking soldier
confronts him his friend Edmond might
kneel to omnipotence Florian says but
that does not mean quote each gossips
dream each village fable domineers in
turn his brains distemper'd nerves and
it's at this point that the storm comes
on Walpole stage directions read violent
storm of thunder and lightning but this
triggers a debate about its improper its
proper interpretation Martin to claims
quote with his convinced thee where's
the gossips dream the village fable now
hear heaven's own voice condemned
impiety and flora and giving as good as
he gets response responds back here
heavens own voice condemned impostor
what says the storm ask for another
scene quite pointedly and I'd say that
ball pose asking it to attend very
closely to this question quote
pronounces it for dear me asks for him
doesn't undisputed in the compass of its
bolt but we is the same loud-voiced
oracle definitive for fifty various
brawls or but a shock of clouds to all
but us in fact Walpole is placed in
Florian's mouth the compelling argument
against superstitious belief and the
credulous or knavish narcissism that
would feed it and would assume that some
Thor norm is some sign from God now it's
a compelling argument but I'd add we
need to remember it's a very very timely
argument for the 1760s were the decade
that saw an intense interest in the
nature of electricity and in particular
its relationship to lightning and
thunder so Benjamin Franklin of Korra's
published experiments and observations
on electricity in 1751 which theorized
that the electro fluid that natural
philosophers had been experimenting with
via electrostatic generators and Leyden
jars was the same phenomena responsible
for the awesome destructive power of
electrical storms many natural accepted
Franklin's hypothesis but even into the
60s 1760s more there few prominent
dissenters resisted Franklin's claims in
scientific circles following the lead of
the abinell ed who spoke out against
identify
lighten lightening with electricity
however the six 1760s drew the curtain
on what became the second act of this
scientific controversy while most
conceded lightning was electricity there
was a decades-long dispute that was
erupted here about the efficacy of
lightning rods perhaps what was the
defining scientific matter of concern in
the later 18th century and in this sense
I'm thinking about brutal detours
thinking about matters of concern as in
conscious distinction in matters of fact
since 1750 to Franklin had been
advocating and installing pointed
lightning rods to draw down electrical
charges from threatening clouds in order
to lower the likelihood and decrease the
deadliness of lightning strikes now many
English naturalist remain skeptical of
their efficacy at all while others
through their support behind Benjamin
Watson who advocated round-tip lightning
rods and in fact the first lightning
rods were only installed in England in
1762 just two years later and just two
years later an article by Benjamin
Wilson alleged that they would in fact
prove more dangerous by making lightning
strikes more likely so while this
philosophical dispute raged in the
learned press and in the pages of the
Philosophical Transactions the
newspapers of the day devoted a
remarkable degree of attention to
reports of lightning and electrical
storms the 16th of August 1764 edition
of the st. James Chronicle reported on
quote a severe storm of thunder and
lightning recently experienced in Boston
one quote the heavens appeared in one
continual blaze as each rooftop
lightning call down the celestial fire
in a what appeared to be a dazzling
array of patterns to the the eyewitness
just one mighty strike did damage it was
reported but there were no points
erected within a half a mile of this
house and so as you can infer this and
so many of the other reports to appear
in the popular press and gentlemen's
magazine during these years explicitly
advocated for the erection of lightning
rods but that's not to say they all did
the 11th of April 1765 gazetteer a new
advertiser published an account from a
marathon correspondent who reported that
quote during a violent storm of thunder
lightning and wind
a luminous body surrounded the spindle
at their masthead which appeared to be a
perfect body of fire may it not be
conjectured that's the editor that
aren't spindles at the mast heads of
ships often attract the lightning that
would otherwise escape yet that same
newspaper a few months later published a
handling account penned by Thomas s
Klein who is the master of the Royal
Navy frigate tartar about an electrical
storm that he went through off the coast
of Florida after first having been
struck by lightning on the quarterdeck
Erskine was brought below for medical
attention however as he wrote he quote
had not been down a minute when we heard
a noise equal to all the guns of the
ship exploding at once the shock of
lightning or electricity destroyed in an
instant the mainmast main topmost main
top gallant mast tearing them in a
million pieces large splinters flying
all around the ship from many yards
distant the sails rent in as many pieces
or threads streams of electric fire
rushing at the same time down to the
bottom of the ship in short never was
anything more tremendous I think this
helps contextualize the way Walpole
concludes his storm seeing the children
come running back on stage interrupting
the man's debate by carrying news of an
offstage conflagration Oh a storm so
dreadful cries one orphan some demon
rides in the air
Martin cynically goading them on Asif
none had the courage to face the fiend
and one reports I winked and I saw the
Lightning burst the monument the shield
of arms shivered to splinters ere I
could repeat in Ave Maria down with a
hideous crash the cross came tumbling
wall didn't have to embellish this scene
we know that one of the reasons why
lightning rods were such a crucial
matter of concern a genuine article
debate is that they drew down as it were
lingering superstitions about the causes
of sublime natural events like lightning
storms with the question while the
question of the efficacy and the proper
design of lightning rods was being
debated by the learning on both sides of
the Atlantic people were still being
electrocuted to death in shockingly high
numbers due to the persistence of
pre-modern beliefs that lightning was
act of God and a sign of his displeasure
and as Mitch I'm sorry Trent Mitchell
discusses in a really great article in
18th century studies in 1998 according
to many contemporaries only truth the
only true safeguards from this
providential instrument were a full
trust in God and a hearty repentance to
move God's heavy judgment so clergy not
unlike the clergy we see in the play
might be using instances of lightning to
extend their moral influence and
authority over the flock as Martin does
but it also meant they actually have to
do something when storms threatened and
so generally this meant the ringing of
church bells but of course this exposed
the faith faithful to terrible deaths by
electrocution if they were up in the
Campanile yanking on wet bell calls when
lightning struck now
this isn't hot some gothic prehistoric
superstition one report issued in Munich
found that over a 33 year period
386 lightning strikes hit bell towers
and they resulted in 103 fatalities this
report was published in 1784 no wonder
that the Lloyds Evening Post of May 1768
the same year Walpole penned of
mysterious mother felt the need to
publish a long extract from the history
of the Royal Academy of Paris on how to
quote preserve oneself from Thunder TLDR
don't hunt under trees and for God's
sake don't ring any bells I think there
are a number of plausible reasons why
Walpole's version of the Gothic shifts
in this way from the Castle of Otranto
to the mysterious mother chief among
them I think is is as we've been
discussing waffles obstinate retention
of that incest plot and his insistence
that this play must be at a heart
investigation how the countess copes
with an unimaginable guilt of an act of
a truly diseased imagination he wants to
focus it on internal struggles too much
attention is paid too much attention
paid to supernatural agents would
distract from his analysis of morbid
psychology besides all people may have
quite sensibly been writing against the
formal material constraints of the
theatre it is a bit of an open question
whether it really
this could be staged but I'm kind of
convinced that for a while there I
thought this might have might have
worked one can certainly will readily
narrate an electrical storm offstage
then one can represent a giant falling
cask on stage but I do think the plays
curious treatment of electricity in
particular is deliberate for registers
and draws cultural force from the
ambiguity and suspicion that gathers
around lightning as this kind of crucial
matter of concern these electrical
debates revealed a certain persistence
of pre enlightened gothic credulity and
while Walpole's protagonists reject
Martin's supernatural trappings outright
and I think they speak in the voice
we're supposed to acknowledge and agree
with the very popularity of this gothic
mode that Walpole initiates exploits
even as it exercises these pre-modern
fears and longings and it gives voice
and form to a wider suspicion of the
Enlightenment project and discourses of
science and it's that wider suspicion of
the discourses of science and the
Enlightenment project that I think is in
the air in 16 1768 that's the same year
as Joseph Wright's remarkable portrait
experiment on a burden an air-pump
and if you're familiar with that the
center of the the the portrait is that
of you know the the Sphinx like gaze of
right scientist who sort of stares
blankly at us with his hand on the the
stopcock of that Arab air pump about to
let the air back in to bring that bird
back to life but were caught in that
split-second moment of anticipation and
fear and I feel like the mysterious
mother as much as his Fink's like gaze
seems to be asking us where moderns
aren't we or if we've never been born or
we aren't modern yet oh it can't ever
hope to be modern what a thrill it is to
be caught in the play of these forces
thank you so much fascinating
all right moving right along our next
paper will come from Judith Holley who
is a professor of 18th century
literature in the Department of English
Royal Holloway University of London her
research interests include the history
of amateur performance her ray as well
as publishing on Laurence Sterne
encyclopedias Siamese twins and grub
Street
she has audited various 18th century
texts currently she's writing a group of
a group biography of Pope Swift and the
scribblers Club she's a regular speaker
on the radio most recently appearing on
a discussion of the gin craze in on our
time BBC Radio 4 her title for us today
is the beautiful negligence of a
gentleman horace walpole and amateur
theatricals thank you very much miss T
I'm very happy to add to this wonderful
thank fest we've been having here I
don't want to name people what I really
want to thank everybody who's been
involved in in making this thing happen
it's been it's disappeared that's I
shouldn't try to do two things at once
it's there it's good okay I'm also a
little bit of a modesty trooper Walpole
E and modesty trip which means it's not
really modest at all but I'm I will be
using some of the same examples and
quotations that you live heard already
and I will try not to I'll try to cut a
few as I as I go but I don't want to
mess up the paper by in the act of
trying not to say something that you've
heard from one of our other speakers
anyway here we go it's generally assumed
that it was because of its sensational
subject matter that Walpole's mysterious
mother did not have a public performance
in his day but I think the situation is
more complex than that it's not just the
incest plot both wool pulse feelings
about professional theatre and public
reactions to his play were not clear-cut
for example the monthly review
considered it no less proper for
representation than Otways orphan which
included a triple
moreover David Worrell has discovered
that it was adapted and performed at
Thomas Tipton sorry theater admittedly
not till 1821 thus after Walpole's death
he calculates it must have been seen by
about 16,000 people who didn't write
didn't complain to the newspapers or
otherwise signal their disapprobation of
public dramatization in central London
of one of society's most supposedly
sequestered advices now the context in
1821 as David deftly demonstrates is
very different from that of 1768 but
nonetheless I do think that Walpole at
some point and in some part of himself
did envisage a public performance and
wrote a comic epilogue for Kitty Clive
to read which we've we heard but he did
say but I'm not so sure that she'd like
to speak it but the responses of his
even his close circle to this story of
illicit passion quickly made him realize
that for the sake of his reputation he
must suppress the play within weeks of
completing it Wolfe Allah Walpole
admitted Rizal schoolfriend George
Montagu in April 1768 he did not think
it would do for the stage and I'm going
to come back to that quotation because I
think that idea what what he means by
would it do for the stages is a little
bit tricky so I want to consider why
Walpole did not think it would do for
the stage and what that might tell us
about theatrical culture in the second
half of the 18th century I'm going to
focus on his aesthetic and social
motivation more than the psychosexual
ones other critics have read the plot of
incest and maternal desire in the
mysterious mother's Walpole's way of
both representation sorry representing
and concealing homosexual feelings jill
campbell for example has demonstrated
very deftly how how that can be done and
how one needs to be careful about doing
it but I'm going to consider the
mysterious mother from it the theatre
history point of view and also to
consider theatre history from a
different vantage point the mysterious
mother was never performed in London's
patent theatres but performance in Drury
Lane Covent Garden Haymarket was not the
only option
available to playwrights in the 18th
century so if it wouldn't do for the
stage what kind of venue was it suited
to what kind of work does will people
think it was and what might that tell us
about theatrical culture in the second
half of the 18th century is it a closet
drama now we've heard something about
this already today closet dramas written
to be read silently or out loud in small
groups were fairly common in the early
modern period and enjoyed increasing
popularity in the Romantic era when the
taste for melodrama pantomime and comedy
were driving serious verse drama from
the public stage or that was the
perception Walpole's played predates
Joanna Bailey's great revival of the
closet drama by about 30 years and he's
a he's such a a pioneer in inventing the
gothic novel inventing the Gothic play
is he also inventing a new form of
closet theater get a sense of what early
modern closet drama was like and and why
it might appeal to Walpole I'm going to
quote mater Straczynski he says that in
the early modern period it was more
common among communities which felt
isolated from mainstream culture she
describes the former's part of a larger
cultural matrix in which closed spaces
selective interpretive communities and
political dissent are aligned it is
notoriously difficult to define closet
drama
Jacqueline Mulholland points out quite
recently that the term has a range of
meanings from written to be read rather
than performed to unperformed all either
because not meeting the aesthetic or
moral stance of the time or simply being
too bad to be performed catherine
burrows has challenged the firmness of
the distinction between closet and stage
especially if that distinction is
figured in terms of a binary opposition
between the closet as private domestic
literary mental and feminine and the
theater expect Acula performative
physical and masculine Walpole is
nothing if not a straggler of bout of
borders the first outing into play was a
kind of closeted performance however
defined on the 17th of April 1768
Walpole and Conway
read the play to an audience comprising
lady Aylesbury lady Littleton and Miss
rich and I don't think their responses
to that are recorded but it would be
hippie so nice to to hear what they said
we know that he had fifty copies at the
play printed at Strawberry Hill press
for private circulation and that some of
these books went astray was circulated
in in manuscripts and that he couldn't
control what people did with his play or
where it went about 18 months after it
was printed Wolfe pol learned that
Montague and a group of male friends
that the boys had found his play at
Montague's house and insisted on leaving
off gambling and drinking to read it
through together he was not pleased
I beg you would keep it under lock and
key it is not at all food for the public
so even Walpole thought this limited
kind of public performance would not do
and seem to think that the privileged
owners should keep it under lock and key
and he restricted access to even some of
his clothes to her and she thought that
they should have had a copy sooner
Horace Mann didn't see a copy of it
until 1779 when his nephew bought it out
to him in Florence and hit the nephew
are supposedly learnt it by heart on the
way man was delighted with it and
thought it perfect for closeted
performances his nephew proved by
performing an impromptu iteration and
what Paul Baines has described as a
pleasantly gothic setting I went reader
ground I'll move on just to mention also
a performance that we've heard several
times discussed over the course of the
day the wonderful sort of delicious
illicit performance that occurred in the
palace in 1786 when Trump's his bernie
chanced upon the copy that Lord Hawk OTT
say Lord Harcourt lent his copy to Queen
Caroline she saw it and that all this is
by my friend Horace I think we'll read
this aloud invited people around and
this little growing horror when they
realized quite what they were reading
nonetheless Walpole did not completely
completely rule out public performance
in the 1768 letter to Montague which I
quoted earlier after admitting that he
did not think it would do for the stage
he added that I wish to see
acted in 1769 the letter to Montague is
carefully balanced it is not at all food
for the public at least and not until I
am food for worms good Percy alluding to
to Shakespeare
thus he does leave open the possibility
of a posthumous performance and he does
seem to have consulted his friend
William Mason on how to prepare it for
the stage
no we some of us looked at Mason's mark
topkapi earlier today and one thing that
should be said is that Mason and Walpole
seem to be an exchanging plays backwards
and forwards asking each other to advise
them so Mason's advice on how to edit
and make acceptable mr. smother comes
immediately after Walpole had just
written to him about two comedies Mason
had sent him and mace Walpole told Mason
one of them's good yeah we should get
this put on but do it anonymously the
other one not so good so it's part of
this sort of economy of circulation and
advising and we'll Paul was quite
involved with dealing with the
professionals in the in the theatre and
getting things put on and helping Jeff's
earnest is someone we've already heard
about as well I'll come back to him lots
of advice backwards and forwards about
revisions dealing with theater managers
privately publicly he thanked Mason's
and wonderful you had your genius I
don't know how you did it but privately
we'll pull rejected Mason's suggestions
because he felt they totally destroyed
his object which was to exhibit a
character who's sincere penitence was
not degraded by superstitious bigotry as
he wrote on the back of the letter he
thanked him profusely for it but taking
such pains with his play for as mr. gray
could tell you I cannot correct myself
Walpole's attitude to correction is
connected I suggest to his attitude to
the possibilities for public performance
and we can see this more clearly in
another letter to Mason this time about
works produced at the Strawberry Hill
play sorry of Strawberry Hill Press
he defiantly declared I hope future
edition mongers were sad those of
Strawberry Hill they have all the
beautiful negligence of a gentleman he
liked the typos he didn't want them
corrected as a scholar and an editor my
first thought is that Walpole is
boasting of a kind of culpable
carelessness and neglect a lack of
regard for what is correct but I think
he has in mind the original meaning of
the term negligence careless
indifference as in appearance or dress
or in literary or artistic style later
freedom from artificiality or restraint
also an instance of this now rare so
it's its freedom that he's after freedom
to experiment originality that he's
praising in himself but specifically an
indifference to professional standards
and indifference which grants him
freedom from restraint crucially it's a
freedom granted him by his class status
whether discussing the moral character
the countess in his play or the correct
printing of characters at oficina or
bata the continues at our booth Tiana
Walpole expresses an our Socratic
disdain for the vulgarity of
professionals in the 1769 letter to
Montague I quoted earlier when Walpole
alkie that he did not want his play
performed during his lifetime he didn't
mention his moral reputation rather he
complained about the current standards
of the professional theatre Nate is not
an age to encourage anybody that has the
least vanity to step forth there's a
total extinction of all tastes our
authors of vulgar gross in liberal the
theatre swarms with wretched
translations and ballad operas and we
have nothing new but improving abuse I
blushed at Paris when the papers came
over crowned with ribaldry
or with garrix insufferable nonsense
about shakespeare garrix prologues and
epilogues are as bad as his pen Derek's
and pantomimes he was on polite terms
with Garrick that he repeatedly
bad-mouthed him in private
so it's he didn't want his place to be
mangled by professional performers
that's one of the words I wouldn't deny
that Mir that the incest is affected too
but he was really worried about what
would happen if his play was staged by
professionals and he wasn't the only one
to satified about the behavior of actors
and audience in the patent theatres the
mysterious mother I suggests can be seen
as part of a larger process which was
occurring at the margins of professional
theatre challenging its economic and
cultural dominance
David Worrell Jane moody and others have
documented the attack mounted against
the monopolies the patent theatres buy
the wrong bunkers minor theaters in the
later 18th century to counter this
threat the patent theater stage more
spectacular productions and pantomimes
to clawback the audience and in response
to this pursuit to the perceived
increase in the vulgarity both of the
productions and at the audiences at
these ever bigger theaters at Covent
Garden and Drury Lane members of the
social elite including a number of
worple's in a circle took to staging
their own private theatricals in which
they could control both the repertoire
and the audience omitting only people
they had vetted private theatricals
became fashionable both because of their
exclusivity and because of the
performativity the funders the people
who acted yes they presumably you had
you had a ball you know you could see so
I did participating in culture is is a
major factor of the rise of private
theatricals but it's another factor is
this aristocratic desire to control what
they perform and who gets to see it
and these private theatricals became
such a fixture in the social calendar
that they were announced in the
newspapers in the listing so all the
major London newspapers which would say
what's on at Covent Garden what's on at
Drury Lane they then say what mrs.
Hobart was doing knew what was
performing in the Richmond House Theatre
they are listed on on them on the on the
front page and newspapers often carry
examples with their prologues and
epilogues plot summaries reviews a list
of members of the audience it
it's like those accounts of big parties
and premieres where all the guests are
listed so the the names of the guests
sir is important as the names of the
performers and walpole collected a lot
of this information in his massive
collection of plays of George the third
there's one volume of prologues and
epilogues and it's newspaper cuttings
and the industry minute indiscriminately
includes both the patent theaters and
the private theaters he cuts and pastes
the two kinds of documents together and
a number of his letters give accounts of
attending private theatricals and a play
that sort of pseudo played that's been
mentioned a couple of times today the
dear which is this sort of satire based
on Macbeth it's it's it's a surprise at
the at Racal so it's not just a mock
play but it's a mock private theatrical
performance of a version of Macbeth so
this the sense of what a private
theatrical is informs his his sense of
the theatre generally says that play
text the whole performance culture the
audience culture now for Walpole these
elite amateurs not only embodied rather
than performed their roles they also
embodied taste the upper classes were
well schooled in music dancing and the
fine arts and some were keen to stretch
these accomplishments further mostly
they adopted the repertoire at the
patent theatres producing a succession
of comedies and cut down Shakespeare
some especially those in Walpole Circle
wrote their own plays Walpole's cousin
Henry Seymour Conway performed his own
adaptation of false appearances of
Richmond House in 1788 and 1789 his his
daughter and Walpole's heiress and de
mer acted Mary Barris fashion all
friends at Strawberry Hill in 1801 the
most prolific amateur playwright was
Walpole's friend Elizabeth Craven the
Margo Vina Vance Mac who wrote produced
and acted in a succession of plays and
her gothic Star Theatre at Brandenburg
House Hammersmith between about 1719
1805 some of these scripts written by
amateur aristocratic playwrights made it
to the public theaters Cravens comedy
the miniature picture had a run of three
nights at Drury Lane in 1780 and
Conway's false appearances enjoyed a run
of six nights at Drury Lane in April
1789 and Walpole complained that the
play was adapted to get cheap laughs so
I think Walpole had no opposition in
principle to the social elites writing
for the public he himself had an after
piece and nature will prevail performed
regularly at the Little Theatre hey mark
market between 1778 and 1788 for him it
was a question of aesthetic quality
equality measured by his taste in a
letter to Hannah Moore he refers to a
skirmish in print about two noble
playwrights the Jukes of Newcastle and
Buckingham a gentleman essayist asked
him why it was more ridiculous in the
Duke of Newcastle to write his two
comedies than the Duke of Buckingham to
write the rehearsal and last I know but
one reason which is that it is less
ridiculous to write one excellent comedy
than two very bad ones
peace be with such answers this dispute
was prompted by an account of these two
Dukes and at the ancestor to the SS will
william belgium included by Walpole in
his catalogue at the royal and noble
authors of england an ever-expanding
labor of love first printed at
Strawberry Hill press in 1758 and
augmented and revised in various
reissues in work such as his catalogue
at the royal and noble authors of
England he builds a case with
contribution of the upper classes to
culture as producers as well as
consumers of literature he is not so
blinded by his class that he could not
see the faults of his royal and noble
authors he frequently Gerdes himself up
to produce his most withering wit at
their expense
for example after describing the
writings of William and Margaret
Cavendish that you can duchess of new
Carson he declares what a picture of
foolish nobility was this stately poetic
couple retired to their own little
domain and intoxicating one another with
circumstantial flattery on what was of
no contras consequence to no mortal but
themselves while people in stained glass
houses should not throw the first stone
mr. wall Bob yet he values this category
of writers for two reasons the first is
that there are not career writers their
authorship was secondary to or sometimes
the product of their service to the
state the second is that therein
dependence from the market in his view
made them better able to establish
standards of taste and excellence
Walpole resisted public performance
because he deplored the current state of
the theatre writing to Robert Jefferson
and 1777 about this gentleman authors
new play Battaglia will Pearl declared
if I were the author I should be very
sorry to have my tragedy murdered
perhaps miscarry and to give your work
strong worthy performers is like
sacrificing a daughter to her husband a
bad character actors were not the only
problem Walpole also directed blame at
theater managers who because of their
enslavement to convention and dependence
on the box-office were unwilling to
foster truly original writing on the
stage among the reasons he gave to
Montague in 1768 for not putting his
mysterious mother on the stage
Walpole fulminated nor am i disposed to
expose myself to that jackanapes Garrick
who lets nothing appear but his own
wretched stuff or that of creatures
still duller who suffer him to alter
their pieces as he pleases in currently
encouraged jettison to produce his
countered nob on which we've heard of
already not at Covent Garden where it
was was staged in 71 but in his hometown
of Dublin where he could oversee
rehearsals managers will take liberties
and often curtail necessary speeches so
as to produce nonsense take take warning
David methinks it is unkind to send a
child of which you have so much reason
to be proud to a foundling Hospital so
lots and lots of metaphors of you no
work has baby of murder and so on so for
Walpole the beautiful negligence of a
gentleman represented a freedom from
rules and the liberty to experiment
repeatedly he objected the way the
French neoclassical unities of time
place and action were imposed on British
drama this I'll skip this quotation is a
lovely quotation about cats in its
pocketbook but I don't need to move on I
want to get a cat into every lecture I
give usually show a photograph of my own
cat at some point anyway moving swiftly
on so we've heard about the PostScript
to the 1781 printing that the mysterious
mother I'll just pick out a few phrases
she talks about people being in
two rules he prefers an ample attitude a
thought and pursuance of witches
introduce some novelty on our stage he
boasts that the cast of the noble play
unlike that of a cost of the whole play
unlike that unlike any other that I'm
acquainted with in particular the
character the countess is certainly new
novelty originality freedom these are
his watch words mostly Walpole asserts
these freedoms for himself but he I
think that he hints that by exercising
such freedoms gentlemen might raise
standards of tastes and reform in the
theater now I just want to end by
turning to to Cynthia that some of my
impetus for this work on Walpole has
come from her wonderful article on
Walpole and female genius where she
talks about how Walpole's championing of
lady die who did those incredible suit
water drawings he was interested in a
number of women geniuses many of whom
were on the sort of fringes of
respectability or or downright
unrespectable and he valued their lack
of training their leisure Dee's and
their independence from the marketplace
and that's a lot of his emphasis in
championing them was to oppose academic
standards near the standards of the
Royal Academy and I would like to
suggest that his his attitude to the
theatre was very similar he's insisting
on developing a kind of an amateur
culture in the theater as well as an
amateur culture in nee in the arts and
although we don't expect necessarily to
find the avant-garde in in the amateur
sphere I do think that this the private
theatricals might allow us to rethink
the significance of the emergence of the
professional theatre and the kind of
complexity that it entails thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you and one quick PSA before we go
on if you saw me pulling my cell phone
out here I promise it wasn't texting my
friends if you are interested in
promoting any of the pictures ideas or
images that you've been a part of these
last two days you can tweet it and
there's a hashtag Walla Palooza and so
if you if you hashtag it then maybe you
can see what others others thought and
captured and reflected on all right
wonderful well I get to introduce my my
new colleague and fellow script
conspirator David Worrell who gave us
that fantastic cut of the mysterious
mother and chiseled a playable shorter
piece out of Walpole some longer work
David is emeritus professor of English
at Nottingham Trent University England
he's published widely on long
eighteenth-century theater including
theatric revolution and celebrity
performance and reception he's held
grants fellowships and has more plaudits
than we have time left today but these
include the Leverhulme trust the Arts
and Humanities Research Council and Lois
Walpole library fellowships and today he
is going to speak to us about the play
under the title I beg you would keep it
under lock and key them is the mystery
of the 1821 mysterious mother
performances and having been in so it
seems a long time ago but it's excellent
opportunity to do do these things and so
probably talking about in fact is some
of the things some of the things which
have been discussed earlier so I hope
that as I'm the last speaker this would
be light but not lightweight you know
that's my kind of aim really but to go
back to that to look at it the other way
around so really where I'm talking about
is not the way in which the mysterious
mother was controlled by Walpole but
really how it escapes so its escape from
control really it's a story that I have
to tell in current count two halves so
this is really I guess so September 1769
is the first read-through of the
mysterious mother and I'll come on to
talk I'll show you on the next slide but
these are the personnel involved in
George Montague's house I've had such a
house full of schoolboys for a week that
they're noise still tingles in my ears
thank God their holidays are over and
they are gone so George Osborne Colonel
Burgoyne which is not the one who
surrendered at Saratoga because I
thought they'd be an American link but
there's not Captain Bosco and youngest
born a parson of theirs and one of their
Squires came all upon me on a sudden and
live riotously from morning to night so
that's the context of how they then do
this read through the boys found your
tragedy that mysterious mother and the
boys as they are they had no patience to
have finished it and we read the Acts
amongst us for my lungs could not pretty
on it through they left off Quinn's
gambling and claret and were the
Florian's
of your play the churchmen indeed look
grave but they threw him his ten
commandments and a bottle of port and
amused themselves without they would
have got it by heart however a few
similes they have retained and a cap
with Warren
some of the lines that struck the most
so what we've got there is so first of
all they kind of captured a character
which is the Florian one so that's the
first reception history if you like of
Florian as a character and of course
what he's saying is that they've learned
by heart some of the some of the
speeches and of course they seem to read
through it so it's in that kind of
riotous context so already within a year
the the mysterious mother is kind of out
there amongst that very mixed group of
individuals who seem not least
completely fully at ease with it they're
having a very good time so there's none
of these kind of darker aspect you know
aspects about incest or gothic or any of
the things which we may associate with
it they associate the play and they're
the first people to read it and to act
or read it through a stage reading
perhaps that they're they so they're
they begin the reception characteristics
of that drama and so we tend to have
forgotten this you know it's you know it
seems to me that the private it sit in
that private theatrical mode in fact
that that the play has escaped and it's
become something which of course Horace
has no control over and so there of
course you know we get him after the
horses bolted as you may think is the
thing and of course you know that's my
point really is that these famous lines
about keeping it under lock and key one
needs to look back at what they what
they have actually done with the text
and in fact you know although he says
who keep it under lock and key
in in fact it has already escapes you
know there wasn't a lock in the first
place if you if you'd like and so that
really gives the prompt for this way in
which that first audience and players
it are completely ease with this play is
that this is how this culture is
receiving this play as something that
they can enjoy as an entertainment and
something which they can learn and that
they are comfortable with so unless it's
some other version of the mysterious
mother that they've got but you know
that I don't think there's any evidence
for that that that's what we know about
that and so the thing that I came across
some years ago is the venue of the first
performance which is at the surrey
theatre one of the minor or illegitimate
theaters on the south side of the Thames
and that's really important it's on the
south side of the Temps because what it
meant is that they didn't have to send
AB licensing copy to the Lord
Chamberlain because the Lord
Chamberlain's remit only ran in
Westminster on the north side of the
temps so we don't have a text um
manuscript text for the before the
performance that they did for that
reason because it's escaped through
through that way so the manager of it is
Thomas didn't so he's an important
character because he's the one who's
probably done the first cut of it you
know as as I'll begin to to show so
that's the theatre previously known as
the Royal circus and it's part of that
expansion in the minor or the
illegitimate theaters that begins around
really around 1818 with the beginning
with the opening of Waterloo Bridge in
1818 because from then one Waterloo
Bridge opens up you can walk from Covent
Garden and draw a lane across to the
other side of the river as you may know
the present Old Vic is the old Koba is
the Royal Coburg theatre that's the same
site and these two the Surrey and the
present-day Old Vic we'll call it the
role Coburg theatre we're in competition
with each other so not only do you have
this opening up a new
theaters on the south side of the Thames
but also elements of competition so it's
a very vigorous community of theatres
not a community they kind of hated each
other you know but it but trying to find
new material and that this is new
material that they found now when I
published the essay I didn't have an
image included in the essay of the post
of the playbill because and I only found
it RiRi found it recently in the bowels
of my computer so that's I think the
next exhibit so it's a photocopy so it's
a photograph of microfilm so because
there were 10 performances there were 10
of these like of course I'm only showing
you the first one there I'm just gonna
blow that up a bit and so you can see
that there's no kind of ambiguity about
that the series melodramatic romance in
three acts founded on a tragic play
written by the late Horace Walpole Earl
of offered and predict and presented for
the first time as it says never acted
before under the title of narwhal Castle
or the mysterious mother there is no
ambiguity about what that play is and
and that it that is exactly what the
play is you see that as it goes on to
say a noble offer and they he refers to
the byron preface to Moreno Valley Arry
and so that's its kind of cue if you
like and he goes on say there are
however in the fable circumstances of a
dreadfully terrific a sort of so
dreadfully terrific in nature that most
most a most material alteration in its
construction has been thought necessary
now first of all because it's a Theatre
on the south side of the term
they have to put music in now that's not
a choice it's not an elective choice
that is because the theaters on the
south side of the temple and the
theaters outside of Covent Garden and
draw relay if they have to do
musicalized versions so the patentees
come garden and Roy line who have the
monopoly on speech protect their
monopoly by oppressing the minor
theatres and certainly in dibbed ins
case he had had people spies around from
the patient ease to see what he used
dude they were trying to close him down
you know as essentially and they were
trying to close down the the the the
others so because but the Pater Dee's
thought that they were playing spoken
drama so this is a musical eyes version
of the play could contract it to three
acts or what I want to emphasize is that
this is not something that they elected
to do this was something because of the
regulatory circumstances that they had
to do and so probably the reason why it
contracts the three acts is because once
you've added the music which they needed
to keep their license of course the play
the whole play takes a lot more time and
of course he would have seen as I saw
that it's eminently cuttable anyway and
and so that that that that is what he he
he was doing there and the other thing
that I I found out only the other day
since I've been here where I hadn't
realized that the time have brought out
the journal article in in 1819 dibbed in
had tried to least Rory Lane and so
Farmington the waffle library in 2017
bought some new manuscripts which go
which exposed and which go through here
attempts to take over the lease of Drury
Lane which he failed now what had
happened to didn't is that he'd raised
from a linen merchant in the Strand
doilies warehouse ten thousand pounds to
to pay for the lease Plus Drury Lane
wanted him to pay three thousand pounds
to refurbish the theater so although the
new theater in the the newly refurbished
Troy Lane had opened in 2000 and in 1812
1813 by the time that he comes to take
over the lease or try to take over the
lease it had fallen into disrepair
despite edmund kean
and and and all of that and anyway to
cut a long story short it came to sealed
bids but he was not there when the bids
were opened and so according to didn't
he felt that he'd been cheated that
somebody at the last stage had opened up
a sealed bid and then put in a hundred
pounds more and so you know he so he had
every reason to be antagonistic against
Rory Lane and so what the play what he
the reason I think he chooses to do it
is that he'd so really it's a spoiling
attempt on Marino Fanny airy which draw
a lane of bringing hours the
circumstances of that play is that the
publisher tries to bring an injunction
against Rory Lane to stop them staging
the play buyer and of course is you know
isn't in the country anyway the license
the from the Lord Chamberlain comes back
to draw a lane but the servants don't
tell the the the manager that the Bligh
sance is in the Playhouse and so they
and and so that afternoon they're going
to stage anyway so even though the
injunction hasn't been heard they the
Rory Lane in in other words that are
themselves playing a dangerous game and
so what you've got really is a way in
which all these theaters
are competing in underhand ways against
each other and so in a way the
mysterious mother is part of that
attempt by dibbed in to get his own back
on Drury Lane where he had these really
awful experiences but this is my main
point really it is a three-act version
we can think of good reasons why it
should be a three-act version it's also
music lized because of the regulatory
environment it's not something that he
would have chosen to do himself perhaps
and and and and so that that's how that
came about there and so what I've tried
to do meanwhile and this is really the
end piece really is that this is the
first actress to play the countess so
this actress is the one who establishes
the role in theatre history Miss
Margaret Taylor and that's an image
offer and as you see there that's Miss
Margaret Taylor of the Surrey theatre
and there she is she's referred to there
Jacqueline Countess of nob on the
mysterious mother is played by Miss
Taylor and there we have that actress
located with with this sorry
theatre there and so I was trying to do
some calculations the other day and if
you accept my interpretation that that
first 1769 read-through would also have
had somebody playing the countess
so all those you know male guys who were
in that house that night again they're
very comfortable with playing you know a
big female role this makes by my
calculation because you've got them so
weak at the school boys as we call them
that so that's the first countess we
don't know who that
one would have been and then we've got
that one that's number two then there's
then there's Glasgow production in 2001
and so Georgina here is the fourth
countess and that's the end of my talk
thanks very much is there anyone who
would like to lead off the questioning
we have once again the handheld mics and
we do ask that you wait until the
microphone gets to you because we're
recording this for posterity
the countess has a question thank you it
looks to me as though that first
production must have been a huge amount
of fun with people sharing the part of
Management Pritchard you know just maybe
passing it around them and I'm gonna be
competing to see who could do her best
you know perhaps moving it as well you
know and the other thing I wanted to ask
you perhaps I should have asked at home
but is them the you know the adaptations
made to the script you know that the way
that they kind of parts have been
blinged up so that the the plot is that
the gothic plot is kind of foreground do
you know them you've got you know the
confessor to come with and all this kind
of stuff
any special monk does it yes the
spectrum Uncas is it yeah hmm is there
any script at all you know that anything
that suggests what they would it might
have
there are a few reviews that I've been
able to find again you know there are no
complaints
nobody complaints you know blinds up
outside the theater and so it was
reviewed but there are not many reviews
and generally you know because it plays
for ten nights it's just a perfectly
only you know perfectly reasonably good
success story for you know for that
particular Playhouse so it's just kind
of average you know it's nothing special
in you know in there run you know up of
productions at that time
I mean Tipton was doing more
experimental drama you know they think
the one that eat that you know I said
that I worked on before he's called
something like the fall of Troy where he
manages to refer to to the Sun and the
Norwich Union insurance companies
because they're obviously sponsoring him
to do that so it's that kind of theater
if you like you know so it's a very kind
of normal but it's not con gardenerd
Rory Lane time time to think yeah it I
would just say it's so tantalizing you
get these little traces that seem to
speak so big if there's a spectral monk
in that production it seems like pretty
much I said about the play in 1617 68 is
not applying and it you know would
presumably be sort of a part and parcel
with a at that point a robust sort of
gothic drama you know tradition and the
question that I wouldn't be able to
answer right as to what extent is the
stage crafted and you know special
effects that mark the you know the
Patton theaters to what extent was that
replicable at SRI or no yes but the
playbill does also suggest that the the
plot has been censored yes
one second let's get Dale dill we're
gonna get you to take the money
there are however in its public
circumstances of so dreadful terrific in
nature that most material alteration in
it's a contrary construction has been
thought necessary yeah
which is to hope has been affected
without injury either to the poetry or
the intense and which pervades the
romance why why this is that yeah but
you see carry on you can walk into the
trap because because you know what would
be the point in saying this is the
mysterious mother by Walpole if it's
circulating in the print culture which
is what everybody's been talking about
so that everybody knows it circulated in
in the print culture so it is a book
everybody's been saying which is known
and then you don't do it the way that
people have read it and and so what
you've got really because the playbill
is a mediation between the performance
and the audience what you've run into
the trap is this is viewer caution
advised okay so that's the come on oh
you want to go and see that play because
there's something going on in it so
would you have taken out the incest why
produce that play taken out but I think
it would have been a version of the play
close to Mason's right suggested changes
referring to some it's referring to some
sort of alteration materially around the
incest which is the music right
that's a material alteration three
entirely that it's drawing attention to
the scandalous nature of the play well
perhaps avoiding obscenity but it seems
like that's the draw like you know
there's something like intensely darken
and you know frightening about the
incest plot here we're kind of you know
we're gonna stage this in such a way
that's legal and at the same time we're
gonna remind you about everything that's
so treacherous about this play kind of
alcohol free wine here is what you're
saying well the follow-up question and
but they're not also comment but noted
in the reviews that you say you've seen
does anybody mention that the incest is
still there
no they do they don't if they don't
indicate either way they're having a
good time just as the school boys were
yeah you know that's my point is that
and they don't say anything is what
precisely washes the nature of the
scandal because we've we've heard that
there are all these incest things and I
think it
Emma Cleary I think I think Marcy talks
about this in one of her articles that
one of the most scandalous things about
the play is is the mysterious mother's
obvious lust that's more scandalous than
incest in itself it's the desiring
mother the actively desiring mother you
kind of rapes her son and I think that's
the real scandal well that's more of a
scandal than incest and representing it
is very different from reading it that
he's more powerful and so you can
reading it is a little safer well and
I'm gonna take moderator and directors
privilege here and say that you know in
this wrote in this work of
representation we're back to some of the
problems
that judith has set out for us and and
the question that both Marcie and Jean
brought to the floor is this did Walpole
know this was unperformed ball and and I
would just take that question apart and
make a distinction between perform a
ball and public yes and you know I think
that that's where we can kind of find
our way in and think about his imagined
amateur and private audiences as a place
where it is indeed quite Performa below
and the intimacy of those gatherings as
we discovered in rehearsal with a very
small group of elicits a lot of reaction
the ich in gag reflexes the you know
these sort of engagement with production
itself that's possible that has
something to do with scale of audience
and the intimacy of the gathering so I
think that's where we can kind of take
take back apart the question about the
perform ability of it into the
possibility of private and amateur
performance it's not that it's it's it's
retrospective it's you don't see
anything going on between those two
people they report it so it's not as
offensive as actually I mean it's kind
of French in a way or a Greek even you
know so you you only see her confessing
to what she's done and that there is
physical contact went in our production
he caught her and you could say that he
helped her stab herself which is phallic
but you know you wouldn't need to do
that in a in a physical representation
you could you could you know do an awful
lot with music which might you know help
make it a lot shorter as well and
perhaps maybe a little bit more
entertaining because we did discover
that some
it was a little bit funny you know sir
so there are two things going on there
as well and I I think if you cut the
incest out
I mean you you've got a very big problem
with the whole play really I mean that's
you know the time eludes to Jetsons yes
the cost of Nippon which is already a
sanitized version yeah hails from so it
alludes to that with a bit sort of a
couple of spoonfuls one of the reviewers
refers to it miss titles it as the
Countess of knob on which is really
quite interesting well and as we
discovered to in in a cut music can do a
great deal of work for you but I could I
ask this is mrs. Paul for Judith really
I was interested in which I really
enjoyed it but I was brilliant the ties
between the way the Walpole controls the
circulation of text using historical
press and describe and assignment
decides very carefully whether it's
published under is no name
secondly the reserve name operation is
circulated among a small group and how
some things are printed but not so
fitted at all in the same way with the
your ideas with the players as to how
that's contained to an amateur
yeah yeah yeah yeah so there's all that
yeah yep
I certainly my text but I might not have
read it out so it makes it quite clear
that that there is no record of a
private theatrical performance of it and
I don't have any record of RuPaul
himself on stage but he certainly
attends private theatricals quite a lot
and that the way in which this the
audience and the actors are drawn from
the same class in a way that the
performance we saw yesterday that what
we saw yesterday was kind of an elite
amateur dramatic performance wasn't it
where you're the the intellectual
aristocracy out there and you're the
same kind of be--will from roughly the
same group up we since it's very that
sort of circularity the mirror world of
the audience now it has been same so he
participates in private theatricals in
that way but it wasn't it wasn't
performed I think he probably did feel
it never anyway so there's that the on
the printing of texts at you know much
more about how the printing press worked
and the audience work but I do you think
there's there's a way in which as you as
you say you sort of answered your own
question the the choice of who he
circulates things to the amount of of
attention he gives to the authorship
that linear that some works are the
author is puffed up enormously or the
the press has its own agency the press
speaks said the press takes on a life of
its own so there's something much more
personal non-commercial I think is part
of the point there know that these are
things given as gifts as part of a
culture of exchange not a a marketplace
culture
and definitely I think the the point
about the actors I forgot to read a
passage just very very briefly two short
quotations from his description of a
performance with the Hobart's in it and
I was quite surprised that he has this
very favorable account of mrs. Howe but
you might know Albania Hobart from Gill
Ray's satirical prince where he
basically he draws a complete circle and
puts a tiny little circle on top that's
a head she was at she wasn't she was a
woman of a substantial means and he
describes a 1782 production of mirth is
all in the wrong at Hamm common mrs.
Hobart played admirably and most genteel
II which is very refreshing as one never
sees anything like a woman of fashion on
the stage the eldest miss Hobart so
lovely and so modest was not acting she
was the thing itself said there's a
sense that there's authenticity of it
and wouldn't you get this also in a lady
Cravens plays that if you're acting a
tragedy or you're acting your drama of
of public importance you have those
people who play those roles in real life
playing the role of King the Earl of so
and so the G cousin servants on to this
again is that less it there is a certain
kind of authenticity and a certain kind
of camp nurse combined in this to bring
in sort of Marta's point about the sort
of complexity the double nature of of
Walpole's
attitude to most things I think that I
hope that encapsulates that a bit
there were a number of complaints about
what the private theatricals are to take
another different view of it there's a
number of examples of people praising
they very fine and/or an authentic
performance
they're also complaints that the aera
secrets were taking bread from their
professional actors mouths that both
though they're taking their jobs and
also stealing their audiences
so when productions were done in London
during the theatrical season Sheridan
basically closed down one of the
privates theaters the picnic society
because they were taking his audience
Jill yeah thank you so much for these
papers they're just so informative and
thought-provoking and I have two kind of
two unrelated things that I wanted to
say or ask about it's just such such a
such a revelatory basic point about the
Castle of Otranto versus the world of
the mysterious mother that there aren't
supernatural forces there and I think
about the you know the Radcliffe monk
Lewis kind of struggle and so on the the
rationalize supernatural but I was just
thinking looking at it
that you shed on it that and also
thinking back to Nicole Garrett's
paper this morning that the countess is
you know read suspect and transgressive
because she doesn't believe in the
supernatural mm-hmm
she's accused of that and then she knows
and we eventually know that no that's
not the nature of her crime at all she
has this terrible past crime sin that
she has committed and and it was just I
was just playing with the sense that
Walpole was doing something
transgressive perhaps in the terms of
the play in not extending faith to the
super nut I don't know how those the the
sexual crime and belief or disbelief in
a supernatural and I'll just start out
while I have the mic at the my unrelated
so just today of it and maybe others
Marcy Marcy or Julia could comment I was
just really struck with that letter from
George Montagu we keep talking about the
boys mm-hm you made the birth date yeah
yes it's a kind of homo social group
isn't it yeah well you know to respond
to your first point it's kind of
remarkable that you know these two texts
but Walpole you see this sort of
fundamental tension in the Gothic you
know we we want to sort of explore this
of there's a fun little disagreement
about to what extent should we assume
that there's supernatural forces do we
problematize that or do we play with it
and I don't know I mean I guess that you
know I always read the the would have
read the countess's problem is not that
she is a heretic by refusing to believe
in the supernatural refusing to believe
in the magical power of
confession to you know enact a miracle
to wipe your soul clean I guess I didn't
think of it that way I thought it was
just a matter of her just resisting the
authority that she'd have to give over
it right so she knows as soon as she
speaks her truth you know she's
basically gonna be you know manipulated
you know subjects blackmail but I think
that is an interesting point and she you
know they certainly accuse her of not
being faithful in that way it it's
interesting that that that serve that
position is put in the mouths of fools
and children right and it's put in the
mouths of you know explicitly cynical
manipulative priests and you know I
think you know you read the plane you're
kind of supposed to take this sort of
you know demystified perspective on this
of course it's not really you know a
supernatural event and we ought to you
know there are way more interesting sort
of gothic themes to explore rather than
you know is this world you know full of
ghosts and you know vengeful gods and
things like that
so i you know and i guess the in my
thinking about it this sort of engaged
in this sort of lightning controversy
and kind of a larger sort of enthusiasm
but also suspicion of this you know
enlightenment science project and you
know in particular the way in which it
comes home you know that there's so much
of interest in doing one's own
experiments and you know it comes itself
a kind of private theater you know sort
of performance discourse that folks sort
of participate in I guess I was thinking
that Walpole is sort of picking up a
similar ambiguity you know why why are
folks doing this are they you know
really you know learning some
substantial truths about the universe
there are we really sort of engaged in
the project enlightenment are we just
thrilling to this stuff and kind of
enjoying a sort of confusion delight and
surprise I feel like it's kind of a
similar menu of ambiguous pleasures that
you partake of those science they're
better performances as you would from
this gothic performance
so I'm just to what you were saying gel
before I think what's really interesting
is that what we see in the reception of
the play where it's non reception or
whatever is a range of sociable theaters
and some are more professional some are
more private and some can be more
spontaneous or not and they are all it's
quite an interesting range and I'm
thinking myself of Abigail Williams
recent book about sociable reading where
she talks about reading drama as well I
think that that's an element of literary
reception that we are you know we have a
lot more work to do on capturing the
range so that's Nikhil I think we have
time thank you for these really rich
papers my question is for Jeanne and I
was wondering I remember reading Clara's
article on the mysterious mother or her
her contribution to the edited volume
and she says or she claims that
audiences at the time would have noticed
these resonances with earlier incest
plays and wouldn't have been shocked by
it and she particularly calls attention
to plays such as Dryden's collaboration
from Daniel Lee the 1579
adaptation of Oedipus but she doesn't
give any kind of textural sense of
actual evidence of reception which would
indicate that readers were reading those
you know reading those plates together
so I was wondering if you come across
any evidence of that I don't know about
reading the plays together certainly
just the responses for example to
Phaedra and Hippolytus when they you
would see more complaints about Phaedra
and her desires in contrast to say what
they saw in Oren ZB or in earlier plays
and Greek versions of I say the phaedra
story or other or Oedipus even so that
they were aware of other store of other
plays and I'm not sure in some cases
from having read them and other cases
from having seen them because the
response to Phaedra and Hippolyta is a
really very much a response to seeing
something staged and spoken about
Walpole actually when he's talking about
Phaedra and I think he's talking about
Phaedra talking to the chorus in the
Greek play is talking about how
illogical it is the responses that say
Gildan had to Smiths play are about
staging it and hearing Phaedra vocalize
the fact that she desires her son and
that's so I think that there is kind of
a an awareness of this body a place I
mean certainly nobody could avoid
knowing the orphan it was one of the
hugely popular plays when you get to the
old manor house of course the the
character the orphan is Mona Mia so I
think that they in general that these
were the popular ones were just lurking
in people's minds I wouldn't give that
claim say to Don Sebastian or
necessarily as you got further along to
say Phaedra and Hippolytus although it
was staged multiple times in the 1750s
so it's really hard unless you can trace
down going through a journal or finding
letters just have somebody as well I saw
this and it made me think of seeing such
and such a play so I don't know if that
helps that I'm afraid we're out of time
but I want to thank everyone from the
Lewis Walpole library who's made this
possible everyone from
the Yale Center for British art
especially Dean up in the back and thank
you all for taking a chance on a crazy
experiment to stage this plane which I
think we've learned a great deal and
thanks to our panelists and everyone for
their participation I have a great
afternoon
[Applause]
[Music]